Ethan: Say it!
Tyler: ...No!
Tyler: NO!
Ethan: SAY IT!
Tyler: *sigh*
Tyler: *excitedly* Gobble, gobble...
*Mark hyperventilates*
*Some epic Christmas music*
*And then there's weird Mark*
(wheeee let's make this Christmas LIT)
(I spy with my little eye a random snowman guy)
Mark: *quietly* Ok,so...
I have an idea, um...
It's November and everyone is already celebrating Christmas,
So i'v got a special outfit.. For Tyler to have... (poor Tyler)
and uh...
Mark: *barges in XD*
Tyler: WOAH! WOAH!
Mark: Hey! *laughs*
Mark: I didn't know the toilet was that close to the door! (thank god it's blurry)
Mark: *excitedly* I've got an idea!
Tyler: What!
Tyler: Well couldn't it get wait?! (grammar on point, Tyler)
Mark: No!...um...
Can we uh...
can we have you wear this...thing?
Tyler: WHA-WHAT IS IT?!
Mark: it's a.. costume.
Tyler: *confused stuttering*
Mark: Sorry to interrupt! *laughs*
Tyler:I don't wanna- *Mark shuts door*
Tyler: I DON'T WANNA WEAR THIS!
Tyler: What the hell am I doing in this FRICKIN' costume?!
Mark: You can't talk, you're a turkey.
Say it... *smiles and gives a little giggle*
Ethan: Say it..
Mark: Say the thing.
Tyler: *clearly annoyed* GOBBLE GOBBLE.
Mark: Okay, somebody ask me what we're doing...
Tyler: *annoyed again* I JUST DID.
Mark: Ask again...please.
Tyler: What the hell am I doing in this costume?
Mark: We're gonna-
Ethan: That's not your real voice..
Mark; ya- YA, *in between giggling* THAT'S NOT YOUR REAL VOICE!
Mark: Talk in your real voice!
Tyler: *normally* What the hell am I doing in this costume?
Mark and Ethan: NO, NO, NO! THAT'S NOT YOUR REAL ONE!
Tyler: WHAT ARE YOU TALKING- *realizes what they want*
Ethan: Stop putting on an accent, and just say it in your normal voice! *giggles from Mark*
Why are you so insecure about it? Mark: ya man...
Ethan: Come on!
You don't have to be afraid, you're around friends... (poor peer pressured Tyler)
Tyler: I hate you both...
Ethan: It's a safe place here.
Tyler: I HATE you both.
Ethan and Mark: *encouraging noises*
Tyler: No..
Ethan: Come on... Mark: please.
Tyler: This is what I do for you guys, I'm forced to do this!
Tyler: GOBBLE GOBBLE.
Mark: So we're just leaving Target, uh,
we were gonna do a funny vid in there with Tyler in the turkey costume,
uh, going around and shopping for Christmas stuff,
We were gonna have a lot of good footage there,
But then Target security came over and like,
3 different people from them were like,
"You can't film here! Don't do that! You absolutely can not!"
Um... Which is fine,
It's their right, i'm not gonna criticize their right to refuse us to film there, uh,
But, it's also within OUR RIGHT,
To list all of target's competitors! XD
So, *evil giggle* here they are:
*elevator music*
Mark: *loud gobbles to the starting tune of "Jingle bells" (thought y'all said that Christmas could wait)
*Tyler and Ethan join in*
*Tyler says gobble wrong*
Mark: No! GO-BBLE!
*All start singing even louder (RIP headphone users)*
Mark: *starts giggling*
*all giggle*
Mark: GOBB!
Mark: I know we're all angry at Target, but we need to channel our energy, to make the best sketch possible!
Mark: *dramatic turn* WHAT sketch you ask?!
Tyler: Gobble! (gobble gobble gobble)
Mark: Shut the fuck up.
*Warm, Christmas music*
*Lighter starts* (ooh how serene)
*music continues*
(it's so nice)
*Mark sighs softly*
Mark: *winds up music box*
Mark: *softly singing Christmas music*
*Music starts dying away* (uh oh here comes the turkey)
Turkey Tyler: *Banging on door* (he has a weapon protect yourself mark)
Mark: *concerned*  uh...
*dramatic music starts playing*
turkey Tyler: *heavy breathing*
Mark: *screaming* (we warned you mark)
Mark: *struggling noises*
Mark: *gasping* (stand up mark. pls.)
Mark: *valiantly struggles*
Mark: NO! IT'S CHRISTMAS, THEY SAID IT WAS OK! (they all do, don't they)
NO! IT'S AFTER HALLOWEEN!
Mark: *one last struggle*
Turkey Tyler: GOBBLE GOBBLE, BITCH! (the turkey gets his revenge)
*creepy soundtrack*
Turkey Tyler: *gobbles*
*casually sips orange juice while one-leggedly propelling his skateboard*
Mark: Oh yeah, ketchup.
Oh hello!
Mark: You do!
Really?
That's me!
Cool!
Oh, that's awesome! Tyler: Yeah!
Ethan: Did you like it?
Mark: Did you like it? Tyler: Yeah!
Mark: Oh! What do you think of his costume?
Tyler: Yeah!
Mark: Really?
Mark: Aw, happy Thanksgiving! Say the thing, Tyler!
Mark and Ethan: Say it!
Tyler: *oh so enthusiastically* Gobble, gobble.
Mark: *markigiggles* Tyler: *really, mark?*